Trull area planning committee meeting on
Monday the Friday the 12th of June
my name is councillor Mark Hurd and I am
chairman of this committee this remote
area planning meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the Coe
mid-nineteen pandemic there are just a
few housekeeping issues to run through
in this meeting please ensure that your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off when you're not addressing the
committee and this will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely via conferencing
software which allows members of the
public to virtually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the government's
lockdown procedures we may encounter
some glitches this afternoon so I hope
that everyone will bear with us as we
get used to this new way of working
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded so members and
officers during each item please use the
chat function of the meeting to indicate
if you wish to speak I will then invite
you at the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak or that you have to leave
the meeting the chat function should not
be used for questions or any other
purpose members the process this
afternoon will obviously be different
and for some items I may invite each
member to speak in turn therefore I
would encourage all members to keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible please when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers
could you please ensure that you
reference a page or a paragraph number
and could I also ensure that everyone is
directly connected to a power supply so
that nobody drops out due to short
battery life and lastly if members need
to leave the meeting at any point please
do make this known and use the chat
function to signify that you need to
leave the meeting now may I ask officers
taking part in this meeting to introduce
themselves please Thank You chairman I
am Matthew Lee lead specialist for place
here at Morton district council thank
you
Thank You chairman I'm Michael Johnson
lead specialist development management
thank you very much mr. Johnson we
staple Hurst and I'm a specialist in
development management Thank You mr.
tourist
good afternoon
fine okay see commercial services talk
to the committee thank you thank you
very much are there any other officers
present thank you Berner could I now ask
you to carry out a roll call of members
to confirm who is in attendance please
thank you
Thank You chairman I will call you now
in alphabetical order
counselor miss Beale counselor miss
field
counselor Edwards prison chairman
[Music]
counselor Harker Master Hocker Casper
heard present canceled dragon cancer
Lycan
councillor maze councillor maze present
Thank You councillor Morris press you
can turn on afternoon and welcome thank
you to cancel to none yes councillor
Shaughnessy councillor Shaughnessy okay
and councillor stilts yes the Thank You
councillor Swain
yes present thank you so we have any to
seven members present thank you could I
just ask are there any other members
could you please identify yourselves
please
absent present Thank You counsel Thank
You councillor Thompson any other
members yet council stamps listening in
but busy doing normal work but I will be
listening Thank You councillor Stan okay
so we have to note then that there have
been no apologies but we do have those
absences okay agenda item number 3 our
minutes of the meeting of the 19th of
February and it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on this date
are found on pages 7 to 12 are approved
as a true and accurate record I so move
if you wish to second that motion
please turn on your video and unmute
your microphone and state your name now
please thank you very much Leslie Morris
great thank you very much indeed
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy please use the chat function
to indicate and I will invite you to
speak ok burner please can you advise if
any other member has indicated a wish to
speak no Chairman okay thank you very
much
so what we'll do is we take the vote
that these are that these are an
accurate record could you now please
take the vote taking each member in
alphabetical order please state for
against or abstain thank you
Thank You chairman councilor Edwards for
councilor hurt for the maze councillor
maze she is still with us
councillor maze will you come back
councillor Morris for thank you thank
you thank you cousin Morris Kasdan on
for Thank You councillor stilts for
thank you and councillor Swain abstain
no I think I was absolutely than that
thank you
and I think we've got council amazed
back now councillor maze for against or
abstain from the minutes please for
thank Thank You cancer maze so that is
six six four nine against one abstention
okay thank you very much and thank you
members gender item number four is
declarations of interest and this is to
disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded that
they are also required to disclose any
such interest as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting if any member has an
interest to declare and I see that some
of you have already used the chat
function please indicate now and I will
invite you to speak
yes sir then can you advise if any
member has indicated a wish to speak
please yes counselor none and then
counselor stills German councillor none
first thank you very much chairman 56 by
Kim Road I'm acquainted with the
applicant non-pecuniary and deed house I
am acquainted with some of the trustees
and indeed have previously been invited
to be a trustee although I am NOT one
non-pecuniary thank you just before we
go on any further that mr. League can we
confirm that date house is still on the
agenda or has it been withdrawn thank
you chairman as the members update
informs members here that item has been
ruined by the applicant so there is no
longer an application to determine thank
you okay thank you very much councillor
stills Thank You chairman the biking
road interest thank you very much
councillor Edwards yes chairman not an
interest as such I'm not sure where to
say this but to note that I can't a vote
when item five as I didn't visit the
site Thank You chairman thank you very
much and I will also add my declaration
of interest that I do know the applicant
it is a non-pecuniary interest but
only because I know him through his
business and context but I have no
financial interest at all in that any
other member wish to speak right okay
thank you very much in that case I will
move to agenda item number five this is
planning application 1 9 /o 1 2 4 2
slash house 56 Viking Road Maldon this
is found on pages 13 to 24 and in a
moment I will call on the officer to
present this item members a reminder
that if he wish to speak on this please
make this known by using the chat
function within the meeting and I will
then come to you in turn and please I'd
be obliged if you could make your points
clear and succinct mr. burrows could you
please present the report please
Thank You chairman this application
relates to a first longside extension
and external alterations to the
materials this is a resubmission of a
previous application which was refused
due to the large size and design of the
extension and also the harmful impact on
the neighbor number 54 Viking Road no
amendments have been made under this
application it's the same as the
previously refused scheme it's noted
that this was deferred from the January
committee for a site visit which was
undertaken on the 18th of February it
has then been held in abeyance since
March due to the current situation here
is the location plan and the block plan
showing the first-floor extension here
in relation to the neighbor of number 54
there are the existing floor plans
proposed floor plans
please note there's no change at ground
floor level so this is the extension
shown at first floor level these are the
existing and proposed and front and rear
elevations so here you can see the
extension with
he contrived roofline to the front and
the rear of the extension and here are
the existing and proposed side
elevations this is the elevation that
would be a batting number 50 for Viking
Road here's some photographs of the
front of the house and the rear of the
house and photos of the rear of the
house from within the garden and the
neighboring properties and this would be
the neighbor there are concerns about
the extension would be here at first
ball level along this boundary some
photos of houses in the surrounding area
some do have two-story side extensions
but they are vermin than that proposed
whilst the alterations to the porch and
materials are acceptable no amendments
have been made since the previous
application and therefore the proposal
would still harm the character of the
area and the immunity of the neighbor
and is therefore recommended for refusal
Thank You chairman okay yeah Thank You
mr. Hurst now under the council's public
participation scheme we've received two
submissions one from a supporter and
another from the applicant in line with
the public participation scheme I should
read these out allocating two minutes
but I don't seem to have those
attachments burn our apologies chair and
it's actually it's we've now just got
one submission from three objectors just
the small submission below on your
script apologies for that slight and yes
we've just got got the one the others
were received too late to actually
include and I forgot to update the
script apologize for that amen okay it
was just as one statement this is a
statement on behalf off that's all we
have thank you very much yeah I do I've
noted your request to speak and
councillor Morris I'll just go through
this very short statement and then I'll
I'll bring you in okay
submission from objectors this is a
statement on behalf of soo Seabrook John
Watson and Jillian Smith our opinion on
the overbearing extension has not
changed and we still object to the
planning application application may I
remind members that all in attendance
can express theirs views on the
application but only those that attended
the site visit on the 18th of February
2020 can vote on this item namely
counselor mais non Shaughnessy stilts
and myself counselor heard councillor
Morris you indicated you wish to speak
Thank You chairman just to say that non
pecuniary interests I know the applicant
but I do two personal problems I was
unable to make the site visit so I'll be
I won't be voting anyway thank you okay
and thank you very much for that okay so
the counselor counselor maze you've
requested to speak yes I propose that we
accept the officers recommendations oh
right you're just going to start me
ahead of me just bear with me a second
the recommendation is setting out that's
all right the recommendation is set out
with the report as follows and that the
planning application 1901 to four to
house fifty-six biking Road Malden 9:01
183 ful being refused for the reasons as
detailed in Section eight of the report
and at appendix one if any men but
wishes to second that motions although
we can still speak about it of course
could you please turn on your video
unmute the microphone and state your
name now
counselor Swain yes over second that I
suppose I'm allowed to second it all
right
I'll seek advice on that so could we
I think somebody can second that burner
can they yeah
yes German that's perfectly all right
that's fine thank you thank you and
thank you Cassie Swain I will now invite
members to make any comment on the
report burner has anybody indicated that
they wish to speak but not at the moment
captain chairman Koz Denise was the last
person to indicate she wishes to speak
okay thank you
I will ask members one more time anybody
wish to speak further on this
application before we go to the vote
okay no miss yes council Swain I thought
you were going to go round to ask each
person to speak on it if not I don't
know but just make a brief comment yes
I'm happy to do that now it now is the
time my comment would be that I do agree
with the officers points about the
impact on the neighboring property and
also the roof lines and difficulty with
accommodating additional vehicles and
that would be my main concern okay
thank you very much indeed any other
member wish to speak in that case burner
could I please ask you now to take to
take the vote members just to remind you
that this is the officers recommendation
is or refusal if you could please
respond with four against or abstain
Thank You Vera Thank You chairman
councilor Edwards
um chairman I can't vote or without the
apologies yes of course let me just be
very clear who I'm calling here site
counselor heard
yes go ahead I'm I'm for the
recommendation
counselor maze or Thank You counselor
stilts Casa de stills yeah
against swing counselor Swain wasn't at
the meeting I don't think burner wasn't
at the that's right sorry at the site
visit of course
okay just for that so that's and to or
the recommendation one against no
abstentions
sorry can we start that again apologies
chairman counselor had four counselor
maze for thank you canceling none for
counselor stilts against thank you very
much
so that's three for the officers
recommendation to refuse one against no
abstentions okay thank you for that
thank you to other members as well for
their comments that then is that it's
agreed that that is refused thank you
very much I'm now going to move on to
any other items of business that the
Chairman decides are urgent and I have
just one thing and at our meeting back
in February and this committee did speak
about enforcement
and I know that we were seeking to look
at any enforcement's which need to be
reviewed and we may do that not today
but at a further meeting and mr. Lee do
you have anything to add on that please
Thank You chairman obviously at the
moment council is looking at doing all
our meetings remotely don't think I
would want to add is that if members do
wish to look at this matter it may be
beneficial to actually not do it as a
committee would just be to do it it's a
meeting so I'm just conscious of the
level of background resource that is
needed to run a committee meeting yeah
and as members don't actually have any
delegate or any authority for
determination enforcement it could just
be done as an informal meet and I think
that would be a more effective way of
hopefully getting a better outcome
through officers and members discussion
but also just the background resources
that we need at the moment to run a
committee like this but that's it
chairman yeah okay want to involve all
the members on that our members are
members happy that that should be we'll
have a further meeting which is
inclusive to all where we can review
those enforcement issues yeah yeah
agreed
yes thank you very much indeed
well members I do thank you for just say
one thing if members have got anything
in particular they would be like likely
to any cases that they're quite aware of
or quite won a bet word passionate about
if they could maybe let us know before
or any questions they're likely to raise
on specific cases before the meeting
that would obviously be helpful because
we can obviously make sure then we've
got the information and the answers
available to the members rather than
just to get best value out of the
meeting yeah I think I think that we
would be particularly interested in all
those which were prior to the first of
January this year and less members have
any specific ones that they want to
bring up for this year and we've been
happy to include those Brian to go out
of anyone planning can sometimes
an arduous task and you've got more
chance of getting a chat with a scarlet
pimpernel sometimes no disrespect Matt
so just as a question should we thank
you for that counsel more should we
direct those questions to yourself mr.
Lee if members want to direct them to
myself so I can obviously make sure that
their trickles down and cascades down to
the appropriate person to make sure
we've got the information but I'm happy
to either myself or Michael Johnson if
you can that is probably easiest just to
make sure actually if you email both of
us just to make sure it is picked up
that'd be great okay
so Matt Lee or Michael Johnson any of
those any of those issues okay so
members thank you for your contributions
a afternoon I will now draw this meeting
to a close at 1:25 p.m. as the meeting
is now closed members have are advised
not to enter into any further discussion
on this forum and please leave the
meeting promptly thank you very much